Bradley tried to get in it'll be  Gallinari out and he's got the triple  one-point game minute 14 and Counting  laughs somebody gonna call now they  don't want to use the timeout now why is  Peverley got the shoe and walking the  other way with it and that's a technical  word delay of game on patrick beverley  you're not surprised are you yeah he  picked it up and eats up and walk  towards the Clippers bench what is it  doing  [Applause]  [Music]  so that's on the sidelines yeah how to  Beverly get to show you got it drew  Holliday gets the free throw  I don't know if Everly thought he was  being cute or not  but it doesn't work right there Alvin  has the shoe  yeah Beverly